as more and more people start trying to
convert to electric and by extension
become aware of the problems with
electric cars stuff like range anxiety
charging times and car weights a lot
more are looking into other green
options and one of the most promising
ones is by far the option of hydrogen
cell cars how do they work
so what are hydrogen cars and how do
they work let's find out fuel cell cars
are basically electric vehicles powered
by hydrogen and oxygen the gases combine
inside the cell to create electricity
and water
and seeing as how companies like tesla
stubbornly refuse to accept that reality
the question must be asked what's the
future of electric and hydrogen cars is
tesla in danger what does elon have to
say about it the answers to all those
questions will be explained during this
video but first let's actually take a
look at what exactly a hydrogen car is
and what makes it different from your
standard electric or petrol car
explanation
hydrogen cars or as they're known by
their proper name hydrogen fuel cell
cars are sort of an awkward middle child
between petrol and electric cars but i
bet you're asking isn't that what a
hybrid already is well to answer that
question you must understand that while
a hybrid gives you both an electric
motor and a combustion engine a battery
and a fuel tank a hydrogen car gives you
only one of each a fuel tank and a
battery and if that doesn't seem to make
sense to you you're not alone because
let's face it it doesn't really make
sense for a motor an electric motor no
less to run without a battery and
without an engine to burn it what's the
fuel for well the key to all those
questions is one word
hydrogen
that's right the most abundant thing in
the universe and the same thing the sun
is made from is the key to how the
hydrogen car works
[Music]
let me explain you see the process of
burning fuel is basically the fuel
molecules combining with oxygen from the
air and releasing pent-up energy in the
process but the fun thing about hydrogen
is that under the right conditions when
hydrogen goes under the same process it
doesn't produce heat or flames but
instead creates electricity the
electricity can then be used to run a
motor now pay attention to the special
conditions part because it'll get
important later and an even more magical
thing i bet you already know that
burning fuel produces a lot of harmful
chemicals chief among which is carbon
dioxide which is pretty much the biggest
reason why the world is even switching
to electricity and the other thing that
makes hydrogen special as a fuel is that
when utilized instead of making
something harmful it actually just makes
clean water that's right no gas
emissions no toxic fumes no greenhouse
gases but pure clean toxin-free water
and i think with that on the table let's
compare hydrogen fuel cars with electric
ones first off one of the most obvious
downsides by switching over to hydrogen
is simply where to get it i mean it's
not like oil which can form in neatly
accessible wells or coal which can stay
in the ground while you mine it hydrogen
is a gas and accessing it in its raw
form is extremely difficult and as a
result expensive now that does have a
solution in the form of electrolysis
which is basically the reverse of the
process used by the car instead of
taking hydrogen and combining it with
oxygen releasing energy and making water
you take water and supply it with
electricity to make raw hydrogen and
oxygen and while that sounds good on
paper that's actually the biggest
problem with this system you see to get
just 35 watts of power to the motor of a
hydrogen car you need to waste 75 watts
in a million different places by
comparison if you gave the same amount
of energy to an ev you'd get 80 watts
instead of 35 making the benefit of
energy efficiency pretty much
non-existent 35 efficiency which usually
averages around to 33 percent isn't even
comparable to the 80 electrical vehicles
offer charging times and range
first and foremost the biggest reason
many people may lean toward hydrogen
cars is that they offer better range and
charging speeds with the option to just
go to a gas station literally gas this
time and get your energy replenished in
six to eight minutes it's really easy to
see why people would gravitate more
toward this as compared to waiting at a
charging station for an hour for a full
charge yes tesla does offer 80 charge in
30 minutes in some models but as far as
the majority of the market is concerned
charging speeds of electric vehicles are
well over an hour long in most cases and
secondly while it's a little more minor
the fact that standard evs weigh so much
can have a strong effect in a few
special cases most noticeably sports
cars which have to be as light as
possible and trucks that need every bit
of payload capacity they can get
something not helped by having a massive
battery strapped to their bottom besides
that is the fact that the nature of all
these cars is to be a lot more familiar
in operation and easier to switch to
when coming from gas vehicles and just
the general sense of security that
whenever you're going somewhere you
don't have to check your fuel tank and
plan around every charging station
charging stations
unfortunately for hydrogen powered cars
the range and ease of refueling are made
useless by the fact that hydrogen
fueling stations are many many times
rarer than electric charging stations so
basically you'd be better off relying on
charging points than hydrogen stations
there are 40 000 electrical charging
stations in the u.s alone in comparison
to only 45 hydrogen refueling stations
and by comparison electric cars are
actually getting better faster than
hydrogen cars can be adopted so all the
problems with charging speeds and range
that are the entire reason why anyone
would get a hydrogen car simply won't
matter in a few years and that brings us
to the last part of our video tesla and
the future of the automobile so now that
we have talked about all the benefits
and the potential downsides of the
technology i think it's high time we
discuss the elephant in the room tesla
as it turns out elon addressed the issue
a few years ago during the automotive
news world congress when a few reporters
asked the billionaire and electric
vehicle magnate what he thought of the
tech he quite eloquently called it
extremely silly saying that it's very
difficult just to make hydrogen and
store it and use it in a car the best
case hydrogen fuel cell doesn't win
against the current case batteries so
then obviously it doesn't make sense and
that's still a reality because no matter
how much you may improve the actual cars
the process of getting hydrogen will
never get more efficient unless through
a groundbreaking discovery and all while
electric cars and their problems are
getting easier and easier to ignore with
technology like super fast charging
literally thousands of charging stations
popping up at a lightning pace pun
intended and battery range growing
exponentially it's not even a
competition anymore that's probably why
musk has still maintained his position
since first making those statements even
tweeting back in june 2020 that fuel
cells equals full cells with no context
and a month later adding that hydrogen
fuel cells make no sense which while
less eloquent than before still holds up
as the future seems much more biased
towards electric technology now i
personally don't think that that means
hydrogen cars will cease to exist on the
contrary i think that because they're
not going to make it as a direct
competition for cars they might end up
focusing on more special applications a
favorite among experts is the trucking
industry because in the case of trucks
load and range are far more important
factors than regular city cars and if
the hydrogen industry only has to focus
on supplying one type of vehicle then
those problems can be addressed too
whatever the case one thing's for sure
evs are not going anywhere and neither
is hydrogen as elon has confidently
predicted that will become apparent in
the next few years there's no reason for
us to have this debate i've said my
piece on this it will be super obvious
as time goes by i don't know what more
to say and honestly if evs and hydrogens
somehow manage to co-exist i think it
can only be a good thing as it will
allow us to have far more options than
ever in the history of cars but for now
let's just appreciate the fact that
we're living in exciting times like
these i hope you enjoyed watching
today's video and if you did be sure to
leave a like and subscribe for more with
that take care and i'll see you guys
next time